طيب استمع الى الصوت الان ربما في
العد التنازلي بدا او اذا كانت قد اكتملت
بالفعل الان مرحله الالتحام حسب الاخبار
العاجله المركبه تلتحم الان في محطه
الفضاء الدولية ما الذي يعنيه التحام
الدراغون بمحطه الفضاء الدوليه
الالتحام هو
زي لما تصل للمركبه الفضائيه
الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه يكون في عده
بوابات ممكن تلتحم في احداهما بحيث انه
يصير الطاقم اللي موجود على جوجل يستطيعون
الدخول الى محطات الفضاء الدوليه لكن قبل
ذلك يعني تحدث عده مناورات زي ما شفنا
الاطلاق امس الليل الساعه 12:37 دقيقه
بتوقيت المملكه بينما الالتحام يتم الان
تقريبا الساعه 4:30
الطويل يعني في المركبه او الكبسوله لما
تطلع وتدخل في المدار حول الكره الارضيه
تكون على ارتفاع منخفض في حدود 130 150
كيلو بينما محطه فضاء دوليه على ارتفاع ما
بين 370 الى 420 كيلو فعشان تصل الى هذا
الارتفاع يجب انها تعمل عده حركات دوران
وهذه يعني تبع قوانين ميكانيكا الدوران
للاجسام الفضائيه لمتابعه المزيد
من الاعتناء على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات